il existe de gros avions et de très gros
avions
[Musique]
parmi eux il y a désormais le rock du
constructeur américain scale
c'est l'avion le plus large jamais
construit
l'appareil à double fuselage est un
mastodonte
[Musique]
sa cabine de pilotage se trouve dans le
fuselage droit
[Musique]
muni de séries acteurs et qui portent
d'habitude les Boeing 747 et d'un trait
d'atterrissage composé de 28 roues
l'avion peut transporter une charge de
600 000 kg
d'une envergure de 117 m ces ailes
dépassent la longueur d'un terrain de
football américain
le regard qui héberge est si grand que
la porte d'entrée est la plus large du
monde
[Musique]
le vol inaugura du rock s'est déroulée
en avril 2019
[Musique]
au printemps 2021 il réussit à second
vol décès d'une durée de trois heures
il atteint alors une attitude de près de
4300 mètres et une vitesse de pointe de
320 km à l'heure
[Musique]
avis aux voyageurs n'espérez pas monter
à bord du rock pour rejoindre l'Europe
ou l'Asie
en fait l'avion porteur servira de
plateformes de lancement au véhicule
hypersoniques
ces engins voyagent à 5 fois la vitesse
du son le premier véhicule hypersonique
qui sera lancé depuis l'avion porteur et
baptisé talon eye
véhicule autonome et sans pilote il
effectuera des expériences et
personniques afin de collecter des
données aérodynamiques et de performance
fondamentale
si tout se passe comme prévu il
effectuera son premier test en 2022